versus you know a really articulate
writer and blogger and he's been
somewhat of a proselytizer as well as an
investor in the Bitcoin phenomena why
should we care about Bitcoin first a lot
of the attention initially I think was
paid to the idea of Bitcoin is an
alternate currency that tends to be more
kind of people with a certain political
agenda
sort of anti Federal Reserve things like
that for people like me like investors
and sort of technologies and engineers
first of all it's interesting just as a
payment system number two is this idea
that Bitcoin could be kind of a protocol
for money on the internet and enable
lots of new behavior so people have
talked for decades about micro payments
you know we now have basically micro
payments on smartphones with what are
so-called in-app payments look as you're
playing a game you can pay a dollar and
get you know more goods on super cell
that's turned out to be an incredibly
successful business model and so in
theory Bitcoin could have could could
enable similar kind of innovation in
payments in areas outside of the smart
phone number three I would say
forgetting about Bitcoin as a currency
just the kind of the technology the
architecture and you'll hear more and
more about this what people call the
blockchain architecture which is we
think of the Internet as decentralized
in fact a lot of the services are
centralized for example DNS and
certificate authorities for SSL there's
a whole bunch of sort of central points
of failure and there's all these efforts
now using blockchain technology to make
those fully distributed which can solve
a lot of problems the last point I would
make of Bitcoin is you can kind of think
of Bitcoin as the largest R&D software
R&D company in the world there are
thousands if not tens of thousands of
very very smart engineers who are super
excited about Bitcoin and working on
Bitcoin related projects you know 40
years ago that the great computer
science innovations came out of places
like Bell Labs now if you look at the
last 20 years the internet Linux
all sorts of open source stuff it's all
come from these kinds of distributed
communities and right now those
distribute communities are excited about
Bitcoin which I you know our view is we
want to invest in things that those
communities are excited about well I'm
wondering whether some of them are
excited because of the technology
possibilities or whether because you
know they have they're like like
hardcore libertarians do you find that
as an obstacle and the eventual
fulfillment of bitcoins promise I think
it's definitely created a PR issue and
that in a lot of people's minds
associated with these kinds of either
extreme political views or illegal
activities all of the great
computing movements actually had
political components to them this is the
first one that is sort of a right-wing
component I think the past were all
left-wing kind of movements the
computing movement came out a lot of the
kind of 60s counterculture Wikipedia
this kind of stuff was sort of this free
information everyone's a publisher kind
of political movement the open source
came out of you know the the free
software movement which is very
political anti intellectual property so
I would argue that you almost need these
political movements sustained these
things like how would you have sustained
Bitcoin from 2009 until it became
popular twelve you know if he didn't
have a whole bunch of kind of research
but imagine if a o/l had one instead of
the open Internet right it seems obvious
enough to us now the open Internet is
better and wins it wasn't obvious in
1992 I mean you had a you know
multi-billion dollar well-funded company
ads on TV they would show your AOL
address on a URL it was very important
that the internet won and it enabled
like PayPal eBay a whole bunch of these
YouTube they were pretty you know it
they were pretty aggressive early on
like YouTube had a lot of copyrighted
material would if the internet had been
centralized with that would YouTube have
ever gotten off the ground with PayPal
have ever gotten gotten off the ground I
would argue that they're probably half
of the service is that people here use
in love we're at one time very
controversial and if you have a central
gatekeeper deciding what is allowed and
what isn't you you significantly
decrease the amount of innovation and so
and so payments are one of the areas now
that are still locked up go read forums
about PayPal and like they decide what
merchants are acceptable and what aren't
it's a it's a significant I would argue
constraint on innovation and so you know
I as somebody who I'd like to think of
myself as Pro innovation like I think
these kinds of open infrastructure
platforms are very very important